[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magacín informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre eliana
valencia aquí damos una mirada en
profundidad a los hechos de actualidad
de la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
la nación más joven del mundo sudán del
sur de los 10 años de su independencia
en medio de un difícil panorama a causa
de los constantes conflictos y las
crisis humanitarias a pesar de que se
mantiene el acuerdo de paz que puso fin
a la guerra civil en 2018 la nación aún
está lejos de alcanzar la estabilidad
los contagios y muertes por ccoo y 19 en
el continente africano siguen en aumento
y generan preocupación tanto entre las
autoridades continentales y las
diferentes naciones como en la
organización mundial de la salud países
como ghana se valen de la tecnología
para avanzar con las campañas de
vacunación que aún avanzan a paso
ralentizado una película rodada en chad
se convirtió en la única cinta
subsahariana en el que la competencia al
festival de cannes el drama de una joven
que quiere interrumpir su embarazo en
una sociedad conservadora se robó las
miradas del público en este importante
festival de cine francés
[Música]
iniciamos entonces con la información in
africa siete días y empezamos hablando
de sudán del sur porque la nación más
joven del mundo celebró los 10 años de
su independencia después de que en el
año 2011 se separara de sudar y se
convirtiera en la nación número 193 del
planeta a pesar del acuerdo de paz
firmado en el año 2018 y que puso fin a
varios años de guerra civil la nación
sigue sumida en la inestabilidad y
atraviesa por fuertes crisis
humanitarias a causa de las mismas
un momento de esperanza después de
décadas de guerras de guerrillas
mientras miles se juntan para celebrar
el nacimiento de una nueva nación
sudán del sur declaró su independencia
de sudán el 9 de julio de 2011 tras un
referéndum en el que cerca del 99% de la
población votó a favor de la secesión
como presidencia de la república de
sudán del sur se refieron fort pero la
promesa duró poco en cuestión de dos
años las tensiones por el control del
estado se desbordaron el presidente
salió aquí respiro a su gabinete y acusó
a su vicepresidente riek machar de
planear un golpe fallido sudán del sur
se sumergió en una brutal guerra civil
que dejó un saldo de casi 400.000
muertos y 4 millones de desplazados un
tercio de su población quiere marchar
firmaron varios acuerdos que apuntaban a
ponerle fin a la violencia incluyendo un
pacto de poder compartido y un cese el
fuego acordado en 2018 los antiguos
enemigos se comprometieron a alcanzar
hitos clave en la construcción de la
nación incluyendo la creación
un nuevo parlamento y un ejército
nacional unificado pero los observadores
dicen que el progreso ha sido poco la
asamblea solo fue convocada en mayo y
los esfuerzos por unir tropas de etnias
rivales se han estancado las elecciones
planeadas para el próximo año han sido
pospuestas al 2023 si las elecciones se
convierten esencialmente en un
enfrentamiento entre las dos principales
partes en conflicto sería darse su
propia medicina y potencialmente podrían
volver a la guerra civil además de la
inestabilidad política sudan del sur ha
sido golpeada por una letanía de
catástrofes incluyendo sequías
inundaciones y el aumento de los
conflictos armados librados por milicias
étnicas la empobrecida nación se
mantiene como uno de los lugares más
peligrosos del mundo para trabajadores
humanitarios 4 de 5 personas en este
país de 11 millones de habitantes viven
en lo que el banco mundial ha calificado
como pobreza absoluta
hablamos ahora del coi 19 porque áfrica
vivió una de sus peores semanas desde el
inicio de la pandemia esto según la
organización mundial de la salud que
dice que los casos de cobo y 19 en
áfrica aumentaron en un 20% sólo en
siete días principalmente a causa de la
variante de alta tierra la cifra de
personas vacunadas apenas se acerca al 2
por ciento de la población continental
gobiernos como el de ghana se valen
incluso de drones para distribuir los
inmunizantes en zonas apartadas veamos
el informe
acercándose con rapidez hace una pequeña
maniobra delicada pero rápida para luego
liberar su preciado cargamento frente a
este pequeño centro de salud en gana
esta es una vacuna contra el kobe 19 la
primera vez que les pedimos que trajeran
esto algunas personas estaban asombradas
incluso preguntaban son brujas volando y
otras decían no ésta es una máquina
llamada dron que entrega equipos médicos
a tiempo apenas 3 minutos después llega
un segundo dron deja su paquete y
regresa directamente a su base a 80
kilómetros de distancia
es en este pequeño almacén donde se
preparan los pedidos y donde se
almacenan los medicamentos y las vacunas
de esta forma no tienen que pedir en
exceso guardarlo y luego ponerlo en
riesgo además hay que almacenarlo a las
temperaturas adecuadas aquí sabemos que
hoy está almacenado adecuadamente si
necesitan algunas válvulas nos llaman y
luego se les suministramos cada entrega
tiene un límite de peso de 1.7
kilogramos con dosis suficientes para
2.000 personas empaquetado y configurado
cuidadosamente el dron se programa con
las coordenadas gps precisas del lugar
de la entrega el envío cuesta 20 euros y
todo está financiado directamente por el
gobierno de ghana para los médicos el
uso de drones también podría ser crucial
para liberar otros recursos de auster es
el servicio de salud tiene un solo
vehículo lo que significa que si tienen
que ir por las vacunas sería un día
completo y tendríamos que gastar mucho
dinero en combustible para ir a buscar
estas cosas a la cámara frigorífica y a
las tiendas médicas pero cuando el dron
lo recoge podemos usar el vehículo para
otras cosas
si bien este método de distribución se
centra en las vacunas sus usos pueden
extenderse para múltiples propósitos
médicos y en lugares donde los
trabajadores de la salud están demasiado
lejos para llegar un descenso rápido
podría marcar una valiosa diferencia a
la hora de salvar vidas pasamos a temas
políticos y hablamos de etiopía porque
se anunciaron los resultados oficiales
de las elecciones del pasado 21 de junio
en las cuales el partido del primer
ministro había men obtuvo la mayoría
justamente este grupo político llamado
la prosperidad aseguró 410 de los
cuatrocientos treinta y seis escaños
posibles las elecciones fueron
retrasadas por el coi 19 y se celebraron
en medio de un frágil cese al fuego
unilateral declarado por el gobierno
central en la región del tigre en grupos
humanitarios advierte sobre la hambruna
que sigue fortaleciéndose en esa región
del país
fue la primera vez que su nombre
aparecía en la papeleta desde que asumió
el cargo en una elección que el primer
ministro había me calificó de histórica
el partido gobernante de la prosperidad
ganó más del 90 por ciento de los
escaños unos comicios boicoteados por la
oposición y con problemas de logística e
inseguridad que implicaron que una
quinta parte del país no pudiera votar
esto es particularmente en el caso en la
región de tigre una operación de
seguridad iniciada en esta región por el
primer ministro en noviembre se
convirtió en un conflicto devastador
esta guerra llevó a asesinatos masivos y
violaciones ha dejado a 400 mil personas
en situación de hambruna
los enfrentamientos han manchado la
reputación del jefe de estado había me
fue nombrado primer ministro para salvar
la coalición que había estado en el
poder desde 1991 fue considerado un
defensor de la unidad en etiopía un país
formado por 10 regiones semiautónomas
divididas según líneas étnicas y puso
fin a un estancamiento de 20 años
pendiente con eritrea sus esfuerzos
fueron aplaudidos por la comunidad
internacional y significó un premio
nobel para ahmed en 2019 pero la figura
de reformador fue destrozada el
siguiente año
sus críticos ahora lo acusan de liderar
con el mismo estilo autoritario de sus
predecesores
en nigeria cientos de residentes
indignados que viven en el estado
noroccidental de kaduna salieron a las
calles para protestar contra los
constantes secuestros de menores por
parte de grupos al margen de la ley
veamos el informe
ya es suficiente la gente está sufriendo
es lo que gritaban cientos de
manifestantes tras la reciente ola de
secuestros masivos en contra de
escolares por los que grupos influyentes
exigen rescates en medio de una
indignación general a los ciudadanos
firmen el gobierno poner fin a los
recurrentes ataques de grupos armados
que tienen lugar en el estado de kaduna
el país no es seguro como pueden estar
secuestrando cuando tenemos un
presidente basta basta en este país
estamos cansados estamos cansados
las protestas se producen días después
del secuestro masivo de 150 estudiantes
en un internado por parte de hombres
armados del secuestro de seis personas
en un hospital incluido un niño de un
año y de una invasión domiciliaria que
provocó la desaparición de más de 18
residentes en lo que se conoce ya como
una industria de secuestro para pedir
rescate en el noreste de nigeria se
estima que casi 1000 personas según las
agencias humanitarias han sido
secuestradas en medio de redadas
escolares desde diciembre de 2020 y más
de 150 de ellas siguen desaparecidas
también según un informe de la agencia
de las naciones unidas para la infancia
unicef se calcula que al menos 13.2
millones de niños y niñas no asisten a
la escuela en el país africano una cifra
superior a la de india que tiene una
población
es mayor
al menos ocho personas murieron en la
capital de somalia mogadiscio tras la
explosión de un carro bomba contra un
convoy del gobierno es transportado un
alto funcionario de la policía que según
la agencia oficial de noticias
sobrevivió al ataque el grupo extremista
al-shabab que busca derrocar al gobierno
se atribuyó la responsabilidad del
atentado
pasamos a temas culturales y hablamos de
festival de cine de cannes porque la
única película subsahariana del certamen
se robó las miradas del jurado y el
público al proponer una historia
relacionada con el aborto nuestra
enviada especial a la versión número 74
del más importante festival de cine
francés eric olavarría nos contó los
detalles
lingua es una palabra del chat que
significa / ayuda y justamente esa
cooperación ese vínculo está en el
centro de la película del mismo nombre
del director chadiano mahamat saleh
harún que participa de la competencia
oficial de este festival de cannes la
película es la única del áfrica sub
sahariana seleccionada entre las 24 que
compiten por la palma de oro y está
entre ayuda en la película se da entre
una madre y su hija adolescente que
queda embarazada producto de una
violación y que quiere abortar en un
país donde la interrupción del embarazo
está prohibida por la ley y además por
la religión el director dice que quiere
mostrar imágenes bonitas de su país
donde la vida cotidiana es una pesadilla
y que quiere además denunciar aquí en
cannes la situación del aborto en su
país es lo que nos contó atrás 24 pues
que si no que yo o que el tout lesión
fan fast es un tema al que se enfrentan
todas las mujeres jóvenes y las
consideramos responsables cuando en
realidad ellas no están preparadas para
vivir libremente su sexualidad porque no
hay educación sexual entonces cuando
quedan embarazadas terminan solas
consideren que deshonraron a la familia
que son una fuente de vergüenza para sus
familias que quedan solas
y yo quise ser el portavoz de sus
reivindicaciones
de justificación lingua y fue recibida
con standing ovation durante su
exhibición aquí en el festival de cannes
las actrices lloraban porque lo que
están representando es parte de su
cotidiano donde la vida de las mujeres
es muy difícil enfrentadas al
patriarcado y también a la religión
después de haberla visto muchos
consideran que es una de las series
candidatas a llevarse la palma de oro
y finalizamos con música del artista
nigeriano flavor y su nueva canción
bernard reloaded se trata de un sencillo
en colaboración con el grand palais y
pupa nació en la república democrática
del congo y con damon y brad rooms desde
tanzania después de su reciente
lanzamiento sencillo se ha hecho viral
en las redes sociales y registra
alrededor de 5 millones de
reproducciones en youtube con estas
imágenes y esta buena música finalizamos
este capítulo de aplica a 7 días pero
los invitamos a visitar nuestra página
web france24 puntocom para ampliar la
información de américa latina y el mundo
quédense con nosotros estos trans 24
[Música]
tu planeta
más tarde